-Congrats on the show.
-Thank you.
-"Friends from College."
so you --
this is what it says it is
in the title.
It's about a group of friends
who are now in their 40's
hanging out.
-Yes, it's about -- it's about
a group of six friends
who all went to college
together,
and they're really clinging
on to the past.
That was kind of -- their glory
years was college.
And so the show is really about
how this friendship
has been great in some aspects,
but it's really held them back
from being real adults
and advancing their life
and careers and relationships.
They're kind of stuck
in college.
-It's a fantastic cast.
Billy Eichner.
You're dating Billy Eichner.
-Dating Billy Eichner.
Keegan-Michael Key
-Yeah, Nat Faxon,
Cobie Smulders, Jae Park,
Annie Parisse,
it's like an amazing,
amazing cast.
-Now this is amazing, obviously
you know some tap skills,
because that was actual
tap dancing.
-You could see that,
couldn't you?
-You could.
-You could identify
that that wasn't made up.
-That wasn't cgi.
-No that wasn't.
-That wasn't a body double.
-No, no, and they asked me.
They said, "Do you want
us to cgi this?"
I'm like, "Guys, I got it."
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Put away the computers,
it's on me.
And I think you guys
can all see.
That's four years of tap
at Jane Perry dance.
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now...
-Four years of tap and jazz.
-Tap and jazz.
-Tap and jazz,
'cause you got to know how
to move your whole body.
-Right.
-Yeah, not just --
-That's a lot of the --
the mistake a lot of people make
is they just focus
on the feet.
-That's a fool's errand.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. That's a dumb --
-That's dumb.
-That's not how you do it.
And so I was like,
this is really cool.
'cause I did it when I was
probably like --
like seven through like 11,
and I was like this is --
this is going to be awesome.
And I had friends who were going
to like, you know,
hockey practice and soccer
practice and football.
I'm like, good luck with sports,
dummies.
I got -- I got tap and jazz
waiting for me, with Jane Perry.
-Yeah, Jane Perry
was your instructor.
-Yeah.
-The great Jane Perry.
-You know her.
-Yeah.
-And you've seen the work.
I mean, it holds up.
-You sent this photo,
which is very kind of you,
because a lot of people
would not be cool
having this out there.
-This is the most
embarrassing --
and I trust you with this,
and only you.
-Only me.
-Yeah.
-And yet, here I am going
to show it to everybody.
-It's okay.
-Look at, look at you tap.
Look at you.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Also, I want to point out --
-I'm so -- the thing
that breaks my heart is
I'm so happy.
-Oh, yeah.
-Like, I'm so --
like I belong there.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Also, there's like --
that kids wearing
a white sox hat and that kids
wearing a cubs hat
and you're wearing like,
I guess some sort of like,
naval ship hat.
-Yeah.
Well, I didn't want -- you know,
we were in Chicago,
so, I didn't want to, you know,
that divides the city.
-[ Laughing ] You wanted
to be a man for all.
-We all get behind the Navy,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
Those guys were divisive.
The audience hated them
from the jump.
-Yeah. That's why they put them
in the back
and you got to be up front.
-That's right.
-Look at how happy you are.
-I'm really -- it really makes
me so happy and sad.
-Yeah.
-Because -- there's no irony.
There's no irony.
-'Cause this gentleman here
is conflicted.
-He is, yeah.
-If we can get a little closer
to see the face.
That guy's not sure --
-His mom makes him go.
-Yeah.
-But this guy is like "Mom!
Is it Wednesday yet?"
-[ Laughs ]
You know, cause I wanna go.